hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our ed talks live
stream which is you can view it as a
flavor of our homeroom live stream uh
and before we jump into a very exciting
conversation with bob hughes who's the
director of k-12 u.s education for the
bill and melinda gates foundation we're
going to talk about
all things education with a focus on
math and algebra i will give my standard
reminders that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about making a
donation at khan academy.org slash
donate
also want to give a special shout out to
several organizations that stepped up
especially during the covet crisis when
more folks than ever were dependent on
khan academy and we were running a
larger deficit than ever because our
server costs went up and everything else
went up so special thanks to bank of
america att google.org novartis fastly
general motors and many of y'all who
have donated at all different levels uh
to make to allow us to support all of
you in the best way possible during the
pandemic and beyond also want to give a
quick reminder that there is a podcast
version of this live
this live stream homeroom with sal the
podcast wherever you get your podcast
so with that i am excited to introduce
our guest bob hughes director of u.s
k-12 education at the bill and melinda
gates foundation bob welcome
sal it's great to be here uh i have to
tell you i talked to my dad about you
last night he said thank him i learned
calculus on the academy website
oh was your dad learning calculus for
fun or for uh pragmatic reasons
uh for fun he's uh 85 so he really
enjoyed it and has actually dipped into
the humanities as well so you're a
family favorite uh it's great to be here
no that that's that's always always
always good to hear especially when
people are learning math for math sake
although you know there's not no shame
in learning it for pragmatic reasons so
uh bob we've known each other for a
while but i always have have fun going
to these conversations because we can go
deeper than we normally go
but i will remind everyone watching on
facebook and youtube if you have any
questions for bob or myself about
foundations about math about education
about really anything about bob's life
uh feel free to put those questions in
in the chat we have team members who
will surface it to us and i'll try to
get to as many of those questions as
possible uh but bob and i have to give
full disclaimer the gates foundation i
think many folks know
is one of the uh largest funders of khan
academy so i definitely have a bias
going into this interview
i will just call out
um
so sign the grant agreement
we've signed the grant agreements yeah i
think it said like no hard questions in
the grant agreement um in fact you know
i was like sure uh
i'm gonna ask you a few hard ones but
but the but but maybe a good a good
place to start bob is
what does the director of u.s k-12
education at the bill and melinda gates
foundation do what is your focus what do
you hope to do in the world
so we've been working with bill and
melinda for i've been working with bill
melinda for five years to really think
about how we can take knowledge a good
research based knowledge and turn it
into practices that can benefit more
kids
and specifically we shifted our strategy
about five years ago to really focus on
black and latino youth and youth
experiencing poverty when we looked at
the data the united states you may
remember in the old days waiting for
superman when we were talking a lot
about how the united states was 15th in
the world
well we looked at that data and we
disaggregated it by race and we
consistently saw that white students
were in the top two or three nations in
the world on tests like the pisa exam
and african-american and latino students
were way down at the bottom
of the oecd countries who were actually
taking the exam so we really thought
just as a matter of mathematics how are
we going to improve
u.s public education and so we really
decided to shift our focus to black and
latino young people and students
experiencing poverty of all colors and
so you know we believe that the
strategies we're pursuing and i can tell
you some of them will help all kids but
we're really focused on those target
populations
things we're doing are right up your
alley one of the reasons we support you
sell is we deeply believe in curriculum
and comprehensive instructional systems
the goal being that you give students
opportunities both inside the classroom
and outside the classroom to master
those skills that are so essential to
adult success so we put a lot of energy
in building full course curriculum over
the last five years and then trying to
scale those with districts and
intermediaries across the country
a second thing we're really focused on
is teacher prep like we need great
teachers
we're lucky to have so many good ones
but we need so many more so we're really
hunkered down on this teacher residency
model where you prepare a teacher much
like you would prepare a doctor or a
nurse where you put them in a high
performing school and give them real
support
and then a final big area and there are
a couple of others but i'll just stick
with some of the headlines is something
we call continuous improvement networks
for school improvement so in 24 cities
across the country we've been funding
intermediaries to really focus on one of
three big problems getting kids on track
and by the end of eighth grade that
ninth grade transition year which is so
important and predictive of adult
success and ultimately transitions
between high school and a post-secondary
experience like a two or four year
community college so we're we're really
hunkered down on those and we've asked
groups to come up with innovative
strategies based on research and data
they can implement in their in their
communities and then we're slowly
tracking those and trying to get good
lessons from the field and and spread
those across the country
and what's your sense of either cynicism
or optimism you know when i talk to a
lot of you folks in the education world
which we're both in
there's people are excited about certain
things but they're like yeah you know
decades of smart people trying really
good ideas but it seems to
not make there have been measurable
positive impacts but but when you look
about the whole arc of things people
there's at least not a feeling that
there's been a dramatic improvement over
the last several decades
what's your sense if that is true what's
your sense of why it's been so difficult
and what gives you hope that the next 20
or 30 or 40 years could be different
well i think we put some really
important pieces of the puzzle in place
that will enable us to make real
progress over the next 10 or 15 years so
a concrete example is the common core
standards those are really powerful and
aligning lots of people along a common
framework to really help folks
understand what works and what should be
not what works but what should be
mastered by students what should they
know and be able to do
along a developmental progression
now what we're doing is the second stage
of that work which is really thinking
about curriculum thinking about sel
thinking about all the supports that
need to be in place to make the promise
of those standards a reality for young
people in their schools so you know
we're starting to see bright spots in
lots of different areas
urban areas frequently
are criticized as being cesspools of
ineffective practice but in fact you see
in places like new york and even in los
angeles in a variety of urban areas
increases in graduation rates slow
increases in standardized test scores
slow increases in preparation for career
and college as measured in new york for
example by completion of the advanced
regents exam all of those things are
good so yes we haven't had a a tidal
wave or a giant transformation but i
think every single day we're making
small steps that ensure that more kids
will be able to complete standards and
go on to a productive life i'm super
optimistic actually uh and it's just
hard work uh education doesn't correct
for a lot of social challenges but it's
absolutely necessary and we have to
invest in that as we think about ways of
improving social mobility more broadly
in housing
and income supports in child supports in
a variety of different areas
absolutely you know i want to double
click on the common core a little bit
because
i'm very familiar with the history of it
but it has since become somewhat
politicized over the years
explain how the common core came about i
think it's important for people to
realize it because there's sometimes
this perception that it's this very much
topped down thing that happened and
what was the underlying narrative behind
it
i can't give you the specific detail
because i was busy in schools at the
time but i was paying attention to the
newspapers to know a couple of the
actors who were involved but really what
happened was states recognized that they
needed fewer higher and clearer
standards and so states really started
to lobby to get much more in the weeds
about what young people needed to know
and do and it was really building on an
earlier standards movement from the 80s
and 90s but really stripping it down and
getting much more to basics so the the
states lobbied and then got the national
governors association and a variety of
other groups achieved to push for these
common core standards more broadly they
were ratified by individual states they
definitely were accelerated accelerated
by the us department of education but
you know the standards are remarkably
enduring they become politicized but i
think 40 to 43 states i don't know the
exact number have continued with this
idea of standards they've modified
they've tinkered them they've made them
more appropriate to their local context
but the core of the standards movement
is still there and it's incredibly
powerful even when there's some
tinkering around the edges and driving
better curriculum better supplemental
support services and better assessments
for young people so
yeah it's still a little bit of a
lightning rod but it's it's really made
a big difference in quality and now we
have to push even deeper and understand
what is it that motivates young people
how do we create materials and
opportunities for them to learn and how
do we support teachers in that really
complicated task
absolutely i always get this question
whenever i speak at conferences or i
speak to the press and i always say look
it first of all the politicization of it
doesn't make sense to me this was done
as really a governor's to your point
like states by state they said it's you
know pre-common core the big states new
york california and texas had all of the
power because that's where the
publishers would cater to and then
everyone else would get some derivative
version of what the publishers were
creating for new york california and
texas and then we also know that in any
standards creation everyone kind of
wants to throw in their favorite pet
project but we realize looking at
countries like singapore and finland
that it's the best practice and it makes
common sense to focus on fewer things
but do them with real depth and i'd also
argue that if you
the correlation between being able to do
well in the common core standards and
any other strong standards especially
many of them very much derived from the
common core
is very very high so yeah it does feel
like a little bit of a a red herring for
all of that focus on that
what's your sense you know you're
talking about you have the standards and
then the layer above that is the
curriculum which is you know what are
students and teachers doing on a daily
basis what are their practice problems
what does the instruction look like
how much is it a curricular
design issue versus the implementation
of the curriculum inside of the
classroom or is it both
i think it's really both what's exciting
about where we've come in the last five
years is when the foundation started
doing this work we really invested in
unit plans the ability to create small
units that teachers would generate and
implement in their classes and that was
powerful there were a number of good
units that were developed but
unfortunately it meant that we were
always individualizing the work we were
always creating idiosyncratic units that
couldn't be shared across groups of
teachers to really improve their
practice over time teaching is really
important as an individual but it's a
team sport so what we're seeing now is
the emergence of a second generation of
curriculum where not only is there a
common scope and sequence but there's
lots of teacher choice and the ability
of teachers worked working together to
judge whether or not they're having an
impact in particular classrooms on a
daily or weekly basis i think that's the
the big next advance you see places like
washington dc doing their leap program
where they they adopted a common
curriculum and it wasn't really just to
shackle teachers and say you had to
teach to the curriculum it was actually
to give them a basis to then modify the
curricular materials
against the needs of their individual
students the variation they saw in their
classes and work with their colleagues
to almost like japanese lesson study
study the lesson implement the study the
lesson understand which students were
successful in which students failed and
then come back and re-engineer that
lesson for the next day so it's real
time improvement it's real time
measurement it's
not a standardized test but it's a
constant monitoring of student progress
that gets the common core is
conceptualization of what we want
students to know and be able to do that
really becomes powerful and um really
exciting when you see it well done so
we're putting our foot on the gas we've
worked hard to kind of identify a bunch
of resources that are aligned to the
common core and we're now in the process
of going deeper figuring out what is
effective for which students when and
why and use those design principles to
push for a deeper sense of quality in
the curriculum space and then you know
you're right cell teachers are crucial
so really kind of doing embedded
professional development so the object
of study and professional development
isn't something abstract that a
supervisor develops it's what students
are learning in your classroom why are
they learning which students are not
learning why are they failing to master
a concept and really building
professional development that helps
teachers sell those problems in real
time that's what job embedded
professional development is about and
that's what i'm excited about and then
you know we shouldn't forget students
and families in this equation and that's
where i think khan academy is so crucial
the the fact that young people can kind
of go and get extra help follow scope
and sequence in the in on khan's
platform
is really powerful and it enables them
to do the deliberative practice that
reinforces the work they're doing in
classes and so i think it's the mixture
of what we do in class and out of class
that can really be powerful to driving
kids to higher levels of mastery
yeah not just young people i've heard
about 85 year olds learning calculus on
the platform
you know
it's
the more the merrier i say everybody
should be on the platform
no that absolutely and i know you know
you mentioned that you have a a renewed
or double-down focus on uh historically
under-resourced populations but also
there's this focus on math and i know in
particular algebra one what is it about
algebra one that
and you're preaching to the choir
because i'll whatever you say i'm going
to double down on why algebra one is so
important but in your mind what
why do you see that as something of a of
a really important leverage point
well you know so i knew intellectually
that algebra 1 was important when you
look at the data it's you know a
foundational language and gateway course
for higher stem classes we also know
it's one of the most failed courses in
high school students who don't succeed
at it really struggle for the remaining
three years that they're there in some
ways it's that pivot point where you're
really not learning your out your
mathematics tables but you're using how
to apply mathematics to solving problems
so it's that first foray into abstract
reasoning and it's so crucial not only
in math but in a variety of other
subjects but the funny part to me was i
knew all that intellectually but we've
started to gravitate towards some of the
math work largely because that's where
the field wanted to go
what we started to see was when we
created the networks for school
improvement for example there was a real
interest in mathematics as a key
subject matter area to getting young
people on track by the end of eighth
grade or it was a subject that young
people were struggling with in ninth
grade so we increasingly saw a
significant number of our grantees
hunkering down on mathematics we also
saw the ability to really build great
products
with grantees around mathematics and get
them out like illustrative map and a
variety of the open education resource
materials that were available so it we
gravitated towards math largely because
um the field was gravitating towards
math and i'm glad they are so many jobs
are related to stem uh and so much is
determined by whether a young person can
succeed in math what i'm super exciting
about excited about now is not only
thinking about algebra and all the math
that goes into it but the emerging
movement around math pathways really
doubling down on statistics and data
science for young people which i think
will will expand the opportunities that
young people have will make it much more
relevant to the day-to-day life
uh in in courses and in in majors in uh
college that aren't necessarily related
to um statistic to calculate
thinking algebraic thinking but really
much broader
so there's lots going on in math it's an
incredibly exciting field i was not
particularly good at math as a kid
but i'm super excited about math as an
adult i i did take a diagnostic i still
have a little work to do on my own
algebra skills
i'm going to start using the word
calculate more that's a new word to me
but i'm going to i'm going to no well
you know and i'll just double down on
what you're saying
i mean you know the stats better than i
do 70 i think at 65 70 percent of all
kids who go to community college in the
us have to take remedial math which is
essentially the community college is
saying you're not even ready yet to
learn college algebra and college
algebra is essentially like algebra one
and a half it's like someplace in
between algebra one and algebra two and
we also know that
college algebra is is one of these
courses that you have to take if you
want to pretty much get a major in
anything and uh you know some people
have debated does that have to be a
requirement but but to your point which
i agree with you know i've met employers
funders of khan academy who say they
divide their employees they run
restaurants and they divide their
employees into those who know algebra
and those who do not know algebra those
who are capable of learning algebra and
the ones that know algebra he puts them
into the training programs they become
managers they become district managers
while those who don't know algebra
they're they're kind of stuck doing uh
the non the non-managerial the
non-career track job so
you know for better for us the world
views algebra that way and there's
probably some good evidence to your
point that it's like it is how you you
can show critical abstract reasoning
why do you think so many kids you know
algebra is in theory learned as early as
eighth or ninth grade in some places
starts to be learned actually in the
common core starts to be learned in
sixth or seventh grade
and then kids take other classes called
geometry and algebra two and
pre-calculus which is really just more
algebra and then sometimes even take
stats or calculus and then they go to
college and they're they're told you're
not ready yet to even learn algebra what
do you think is going on
i think we just need to rethink how we
teach algebra uh and all the mathematics
that lead up to algebra and then make
algebra relevant to young people in
their lives so i think it ranges from
the dearth of really high quality
teachers we've done a lousy job
preparing math teachers we can do a
better job and we're seeing some
exemplary programs exist across the
country i think they're real challenges
in making math relevant so we've
sometimes adopted pedagogies that don't
necessarily show why we're learning a
particular math problem why it evolved
in the history of mathematics and what
problem it's solving so i think making
it much more relevant just in its own
history is important but then what
problems can you solve in the world
using this math i remember i've sat in
math classes that were just deadly and
then i've sat in math classes that were
so exciting because the teacher was
making math real in the lives of kids in
the lives of communities
in the lives of workers what are you
going to need when you're you're growing
up and and
and functioning in a job what kind of
math is going to be essential to doing
that job well
so i think you know there's a whole
pedagogical aspect of math and then you
know the new technologies really give us
opportunities to try to think about math
in different ways some people learn math
by visualizing it other people learn
math through multiple ways of solving a
problem to get the right answer
all of those those new strategies and
techniques are powerful so in a word
creating more coherence creating greater
relevance and creating a pedagogy that
enables young people to persist and
succeed over time i think if we can
really institutionalize and scale those
tools we're going to see
a rapid growth in math over the next
five to ten years
and what's your sense of just students
foundational knowledge because you know
to some degree when they go to college
in the college saying you're not even
ready to learn algebra yet
it's almost a a side effect a byproduct
of year after year maybe the students
didn't have the foundations to go to the
next course but the next course was
being taught and then all of a sudden it
gets enforced at the college level which
is you could imagine incredibly
demoralizing
you know i visited i visited middle
school classes that should be learning
algebra where it's clear that a good
number of the kids are you know you ask
them eight times seven
they know what multiplication is but
they have to recompute it they they
don't immediately jump to oh it's 56
they don't and then all that
computational knowledge what's what's
the
how do you think we can address that
this ability for students to make sure
they have strong foundations so that
we're building on top of that as opposed
to just promoting them year after year
and then they eventually become part of
that 70 statistic
it's a great question i think one of the
challenges is to understand with greater
precision what students know and don't
know in a particular area so
foundational skills are essential right
but foundational skills and knowledge
are crucial and not fluidity in math as
defined by time for example
one of the things i didn't mention but i
think about a lot because of my own
personal experience in mathematics is
what turns a person on to believe that
they're a math person or what alienates
a person from being a math person early
on in their lives that's true of writing
that's true of reading but in math in
particular why is it that so many young
kids particularly girls particularly
poor kids don't think of themselves as
math people even though they may have
the native ability to do the work and
you know in my own experience
i screwed up and stayed i was in a
parochial school i was in math i fell
behind i became embarrassed about that i
was able to through the intervention of
a really good teacher who brought me
back at the end of the year didn't make
me feel bad said we're going to work on
this together paste it that
individualization that's so crucial for
many young people in in education
she did that for a number of years and
was able to kind of really bring me back
in a six month period to be back on
grade level i was lucky
i think lots of young people that i've
spoken with don't have teachers like
that who have the time or resource and
facility
to be able to give the individualization
if i hadn't gotten that i'm sure i would
have been alienated from math
disenfranchised from math not believing
i was good at math and then slowly
getting alienated and not motivated so i
think it's foundational skills and i
think it's the way we emphasize those
foundational skills to build math
identity and um enthusiasm for math it's
it's not only being able to do math but
i hope we can get to a place where kids
actually enjoy math because it's an
incredibly elegant and beautiful way of
representing the universe you know i
once had a math teacher who said a
beautiful problem is like a beautiful
poem uh i don't think if i'm that far
i'm much more a poetry person than a
beautiful problem in math person but i
think there's a real grain of truth in
that the more we can excite students
about math in that way the more likely
we're able to we will see uh gains in
student achievement
yeah well i i know i agree i love poetry
too but sometimes
when you see a beautiful product in math
or a beautiful it says something very
deep about the universe that's what's
amazing you know the math that you're
doing is just abstract
symbols but it's representing a very
pure idea uh that i think sometimes can
can give you chills i mean i can i could
i could start geeking out on on all of
those things you know there's a lot of
talk right now because of the pandemic
learning loss kids who have been
disengaged i'm curious about what y'all
have been seeing on that front but also
in this last bill coming through
congress 120 i think six billion dollars
is going down to the states which will
then go to the districts in the schools
20 percent of which has been
kind of tagged for learning loss this is
a lot of money that is flowing into the
states into school systems what's your
hopes and fears there what do you think
this can be a long-term accelerant
because i don't think there's ever been
an example of this much money flowing to
schools this quickly
well just to give you an example we
spend 300 million dollars a year at the
gates foundation on public education
schools are about to receive 120 billion
dollars a year so that really dwarfs
everything that's occurring in
philanthropy so one of the things we've
been working on is to really try to
think about how to create coherence and
coordination so people don't just spend
money on the best idea that they've
thought through but they really are
connected to the research and thinking
hard about what are the elements that
students need to be successful
so over the last few weeks we've been
working with three really outstanding
groups
uh council of chief state school
officers
chiefs for change and the council of
great city schools to really build out a
10-point framework on key elements that
need to be addressed in any recovery
effort and then really start to
disseminate that and figure out what are
the best practices best organizations
uh and and tools and resources that can
be implemented in each one of those
areas so concretely we know that much of
the learning loss need for acceleration
has been
created by the digital divide we still
have eight to 12 million students who
don't have regular access either to
equipment or excessive access to the
internet we need to solve that problem
and hopefully
seven billion of the dollars that are
going through that stimulus package are
designed to go through the fcc and start
to address it we're gonna have to
continue to work with districts and
states to both solve the problem in the
short term but then in the long term but
then you know what are the strategies
that are research-based that can be
helpful curriculum is really important
end of your courses is really important
opportunities to go on khan academy and
do the extra homework is really
important but they're also just
individual needs like tutoring we've
been lucky to work with a variety of
different tutoring groups that have seen
real advances of you know acceleration
of one to two years in a year of
tutoring so
it'll really be about identifying those
best practices and coordinating
i'm sure like you i really have the
opportunity to talk to a lot of
superintendents and chiefs around the
country it's one of the
joys of my job and i have to say i've
been blown away by how thoughtful people
are
absorbing this amount of money in ways
that are is sustainable over time and
really enables us to build back better
but build back braver is going to be
crucial and i i think you know in the
next
two or three months we're going to see
some really interesting plans coming
from a variety of different districts
addressing learning loss addressing
social emotional needs thinking hard
about the digital divide thinking hard
about you know the host of things that
need to happen to enable our young
people to recover quickly
completely agree i've actually just
actually last friday started because i
talked to so many of these uh
superintendents of large districts chief
academic officers
state commissioners or state
superintendents and they are all both
excited and fearful of what's about to
happen because it's a huge opportunity
to do a lot of good but there's a lot of
political pressure to put the money to
work fast but also not to squander which
is reasonable political pressure on both
fronts uh but because of but i've been
very impressed with how people have been
thinking about it you know how do you
ramp into it it's over roughly the next
uh three three years or so and how do
you not make it so it's just this blip
and then it doesn't sustain itself how
do you use these resources to do real
structural change and obviously i've had
my bigger hat the khan academy hat which
uh plays a role uh where kids can
asynchronously get practice feedback and
work in a classroom and then this new
effort around schoolhouse.world which is
around tutoring which is exactly why
this focus on tutoring because it's
great to be able to go to a khan academy
but unless you have folks to mentor you
coach you you have a community to be in
it's a it's a lot harder for a lot of
students to be able to engage at that
level so yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how all of how all
this evolves i want to make sure i get
to
questions from folks let's see i've
asked some of these well i'll ask one
which is kind of a fun question it's a
less than deep policy question but i
think you have a unique vantage point
this is from smartbear on youtube
what does it feel like working with bill
and melinda what are they like
what are bill and melinda like bill and
linda are fantastic uh
you know i've been in meetings with you
saul you know that bill is uh one of the
smartest people you'll ever deal with
he uh really wants to ask the hard
questions kick the tires he has a point
of view he tells you what that point of
view is and he really expects you to
tell your point of view back and not be
intimidated uh by him and we've had just
amazing conversations i never walk into
the room i feel like i know a lot about
education but i never walk in the room
not learning something from bill and not
learning something from melinda they're
incredibly thoughtful and incredibly
committed to this work they've been
doing it now for 23 24 years and they're
really in it for the long haul they
really want to ensure that
you know the foundation's motto is all
lives have equal value they want to make
sure that every young person has a good
education and can
meet their potential and and it's it's a
real pleasure you know i was trained
originally as a lawyer so i
conceptualize every meeting with bill
gates is a little bit like a supreme
court argument you get about five
minutes to state your case and then you
better be ready for the questions
because they're fast and furious but
they're always directed towards the
larger purpose of what we're trying to
do
yeah no i have to you you spent more
time with them but but in my
interactions um you know bill is one of
the few people that you know in in my
meeting he's able to push hard and and
and he pushes hard on all the exact
right places how do we know we're
reaching the right kids how do we know
we're getting traction how do we know
we're supporting teachers how do we know
um and then like the next meeting could
be with people who are like working on
health care or you know fighting polio
or whatever and then he pushes them too
like you know these are the experts in
the field so i don't feel uh a as bad
and you know not being intimidated by
bill is easier said than done but it's
it's good in terms of
no other
it's easier said than done um let's see
in the i see we're almost out of time
but let's let's make sure i have a a
uh one one one more
question well this is a question from
charles lamar drayden on facebook asking
uh is there you know well i'll
paraphrase the question you know your
views on standardized testing uh and the
question is saying measurement tools
showing correlation between success and
standardized testing but what are your
views on standardized testing it's a bit
of a hot topic but i always say what
part do you disagree with the
standardized or the testing or is there
something else or how you use it how do
you how do you view it
i think tests are important i think we
need to be innovating a lot more in the
space to be honest with you i uh you
know one thing that's fascinating is
grades are very predictive of adult
success extraordinarily predictive that
may be a matter of statistics it's
multiple opportunities to view some
young person it has sel and executive
function skills embedded in it it can
also be very damaging to a student if it
doesn't really include opportunities to
rethink and redo work
so i think we need assessments i think
testing is good i think part of
learning is having a little anxiety but
what you're learning to retain it and
then ultimately synthesizing it with
other things over the course of the year
but we need to make sure that the tests
we give are are usable for families
usable for students and
and ultimately usable uh to advance uh
equity so
i think of it i guess the the
the reality for me is there are four
things we ask tess to do and it may be
too many and we need to start thinking
about that we need tests to give
students feedback on where they are we
need tests to give teachers feedback on
where students are and what they should
do next we need tests that enable us to
compare schools and make sure we're
living up to our equity responsibilities
and ultimately we need tests to place
students at the next level of education
in ways that are appropriate with their
skills interests uh and abilities so um
you know i think we need to do a lot
more in assessment and i think at the
foundation we're committed to innovating
around it
no i couldn't agree more you know
there's nothing wrong with testing
nothing wrong with standardized but
there's other ways to do it uh because
now when you do work on an online
platform it is standardized and it is
assessing uh where you are but it's
continuous it can be part of part of the
learning and also you can make it more
actionable so it's not there's there's
ways to do it that maybe solve some of
the the issues and then if you make it
actionable uh where you're actually able
to make positive constructive actions
based on it then it could be a good
thing so so bob i know we're we're over
time maybe just you know final thoughts
on anyone listening you know we have
parents listening we have students
listening we have teachers
what would be the big takeaway that you
would want them to have for their own
lives or their own children's lives uh
and then and then for the education
system as a whole
i would just say we're coming off of
incredibly complicated time with the
covet pandemic it's going to be super
challenging to address lots of the
problems that young people have at this
moment but just lean in
i know teachers are going to be leaning
in schools are going to be leaning in we
have resources to be really creative
and and i think it's important to
address what harm students have
experienced over the last
year year and a half but i also think we
need to be a little brave and think
about how can we transform the system so
we don't go back to where we were where
we had difficulties and challenges but
we build a system that more effectively
addresses the needs of young people that
more effectively support students and
our story parents and communities in
that education process that
uses technology in new ways we know
everybody's had an experience of a
virtual platform at this point how do we
take what was sometimes
ranch actor quickly put together and
actually use it to drive
a better type of personalization for
young people so i think it's a time of
incredible promise if we lean into it
real challenges as there always are but
real opportunities if we're brave enough
to seize them
right well bob thanks so much uh you
know chatting with you and obviously we
collaborate on a lot of fronts it always
leaves me energized and excited about uh
and i agree with you i think uh the the
future is i think we're at a point where
sometimes it's darkest before the dawn
and there's a lot of really exciting
things that i think will fundamentally
accelerate a lot of folks learning over
the next 10 years thank you so much for
for joining us
well saul thanks for everything you do
and thanks to the team at khan you guys
do amazing work we're really proud to
sponsor you
thank you so much means a lot to us and
all the people listening
well well thanks everyone for for
joining hopefully you enjoyed that
conversation with bob as much as i did i
look forward uh for future conversations
like that and and uh please join us at
the next ed talks and or homeroom uh
with that i'll see you i think i'm i'm i
think this is the last one for my week
and then i'm going on vacation so it
might be a little while since we see
each other but
stay tuned
you